y empieza nuestro espacio de salud aquí
en directo América y como siempre nos
acompaña mar Romero salamar Buenos días
para usted cómo está Buenos días María
Clara vamos a Brasil porque el gobierno
declaró emergencia sanitaria en la
comunidad indígena Llano Mami cuéntenos
por qué si hace una aproximadamente una
semana de esta declaratoria en una en un
territorio que es la reserva más grande
indígena de Brasil son aproximadamente
10 millones de hectáreas donde viven más
de 30.000 personas ya no [__] y estas
comunidades están aquejadas por un
aumento exponencial de casos de malaria
también por graves casos de desnutrición
contaminación de mercurio de las
personas y de los ecosistemas y además
con un acceso a la atención sanitaria
muy pobre No señalan directamente a la
minería ilegal que hay en el territorio
hay 30.000 ya no [__] como decíamos
conviviendo conviviendo si se puede
decir así con 20.000 personas que
trabajan en la minería ilegal algo que
es totalmente disruptivo con sus formas
de vida el presidente Lula que viajó al
territorio esta semana también llegó a
tacharlo de genocidio y está
investigando al gobierno anterior del
presidente bolsonaro
lo que he visto es inhumano Honestamente
si el presidente y que dejó el cargo
hace pocos días tuviera un poco de
vergüenza y hubiera venido aquí al menos
una vez quizás esta gente no estaría tan
mal en este nivel de abandono
y para entender Por qué Lula habla de
genocidio Marco cuéntenos Cuáles son las
consecuencias de la minería ilegal en
estos territorios para empezar una de
las cosas de las que hablan es del miedo
y de la intimidación de estos Mineros de
actividades ilegales además que llevan a
cabo y que además suelen ir armados
escuchemos la denuncia
llevamos cuatro años sin asistencia
sanitaria en las comunidades 120
comunidades luchando por su vida
más de 20.000 mineros en territorio
indígena ya no mami con armas
intimidando a las comunidades vivimos
con miedo
En qué se traduce Pues básicamente no
poder circular libremente lo que
significa que hay problemas para recibir
atención sanitaria pero también para
desarrollar pues sus actividades de
subsistencia Además del grave problema
del mercurio que acarrea la minería de
oro sobre todo El Mercurio es altamente
tóxico contamina el entorno del que
dependen de los llanomami tanto pues
para comer y para vivir y digamos aquí
hemos repasado algunos de los efectos
que tiene no para empezar consumir
mercurio muchas veces por ejemplo a
través de los pescados de los peces que
viven en el río donde se vierte El
mercurio de la minería afecta al sistema
inmune también el sistema renal el
sistema digestivo es corrosivo también
puede afectar la piel Incluso el sistema
respiratorio y el más conocido el
sistema nervioso estamos hablando de que
puedes tener problemas de memoria
dificultades para moverse disfunciones
cognitivas eso especialmente durante el
desarrollo del feto durante el momento
del embarazo bueno y digamos que es un
poco más claro esta relación entre el
mercurio y la salud y la afectación a la
población ya no mami pero cómo tiene que
ver la minería ilegal con la malaria
Pues básicamente se reduce a un problema
de aumento de personas no Un aumento
exponencial en un lugar donde vivían
30.000 personas Ahora hay 20.000 más que
llegaron que vienen de otros territorios
Y que además se mueven mucho más por
todos estos pues hectáreas de territorio
mucho más que los mismos indígenas que
viven ahí Entonces eso aumenta la
transmisión también porque la minería
Deja esos pozos de agua estancados muy
grandes donde se reproduce el mosquito
que luego es el vector de esta
enfermedad todo esto además pues como
decíamos Suele suceder en zonas de poca
de poca pues asistencia médica en el que
es difícil cortar las cadenas de
transmisión hay un estudio de hecho que
se hizo en Venezuela que llegó a
cuantificar el impacto de la minería
ilegal sobre los aumentos de casos de
malaria no y concluía que la minería
ilegal había provocado Un aumento del
27% de los casos de malaria provocados
por el parásito plasmo de un falso y un
23% por el caso del plasmodium vivax es
el más prevalente en América Latina
entonces bueno Esto que vemos que sucede
en Venezuela no debe ser muy distinto de
lo que está sucediendo en Brasil en el
estado de roraima donde viven los
llanomamis donde han denunciado este
pues incremento exponencial de casos de
malaria mar pero más allá de ir al sitio
como lo hizo el presidente de Lula da
Silva Qué está haciendo el gobierno de
Brasil para responder ante esto pues
primero de todo dar más apoyo y más
asistencia sanitaria a estas comunidades
no hay un informe de hecho que
publicaron las mismas comunidades Llano
mami en las que pues daban cifras de
cómo ha caído esta atención sanitaria
daban el ejemplo de dos territorios en
el que veíamos que entre 2020 y 2021
habían caído más de un 70 más de un 80%,
las atenciones sanitarias que se habían
hecho en ese territorio además en
boavista que es la capital del Estado de
roraima se está atendiendo muchas de
estas personas afectadas a muchas de
estas víctimas y Digamos que ya más a
largo plazo pues sabemos que el gobierno
de Lula se ha comprometido veremos Si lo
consigue si lo hace efectivo terminar
con la minería ilegal que afecta a estos
territorios y especialmente en las
reservas indígenas donde de nuevo no se
puede hacer actividades extractivistas
veremos qué sucede en el Pues en el
futuro y Seguiremos muy atentos Pues
esperemos que nos siga aumentando ni la
malaria ni las enfermedades por mercurio
Omar gracias por este completo informe
Gracias a ti María